the interesting thing about all of the
stuff we see with the far left is that
it is
what i would call like the um in terms
of a weapon
if you were like crit analogy it's a
blunt object yeah whereas
the extremist stuff we normally see with
like mass shooters is like
a knife the way what i mean by that is
you take someone with a knife you're
going to end them really quickly yeah
and it's like a high
you know uh it's intense it's a yeah
right and a blunt object is
slow and if you hit someone with a bat
once they might just run away
so you can you can theoretically hit a
thousand people with a baseball bat
over the course of a month and it won't
make the news
nobody cares you want somebody and stab
them it's going to be front page on the
local news you do to several people
it'll be major news and so what ends up
happening is you have these terror
attacks where the mainstream media
sees it and rightly so goes like whoa
this dude ran into a room with the gun
and shot all these people
and then everyone talks about how
right-wing violence is the most extreme
and it's like it's certainly a problem
absolutely we we gotta have the fed
stopping all this stuff
but with the low-tier stuff from the
left they do it a hundred times more
often
but it never makes the news so it keeps
happening right
now donald trump announced something
earlier along in this along with the
press conference where he talked about
car written as he says
this is from uh felicia sonmez felicia
is washington post national political
reporter dhs and doj
are announcing a joint operations center
to investigate violent for
a violent left-wing civil unrest trump
says
good awesome yep so it strikes me that
it would be much simpler to just say
all extremists left and right or bad why
can't we just do that
well apparently now that's what joe
biden's trying to do oh boy wait let me
see if i can find out here
here we go this is great tyler uh and
i'm gonna go back to that tweet because
this is another funny thing there tyler
pager says
biden on trump's presser i urge the
president to join me in saying that
while peaceful
protest is a right a necessity violence
is wrong
period if donald trump can't say that
then he is unfit to be president
and his preference for more violence not
less is clear
yeah why doesn't he say that tim take a
look at this tweet below
someone commented we've reached levels
of gaslighting never before thought
possible
i couldn't believe this so i actually
pulled it up and yep look at this
biden i condemn violence in portland
challenge donald trump to do the same
biden condemns violence in portland and
calls on trump to do the same
biden condemns portland violence says
trump recklessly encouraging it
wow trump is recklessly encouraging it
that's
crazy you know what you know what was
really crazy to me when i saw this
i think this proves that joe biden and
and like
kamala and the democrats no longer care
for politically active people
like they're straight up saying if you
follow the news
and you listen to commentary we don't
want your vote
you know why why because we've all been
listening to trump
scream his head off right about ending
the violence and having law and order
and they keep blaming him for it even
though it's like
we just had ted wheeler of portland
write a letter
and say i do not want your help ending
the violence
yep yep and then what did he do the next
day
what he did a press conference where he
blamed donald trump for not intervening
and if you don't want to help us get out
of our way
support us or get the hell out of the
way what do you think he tried to do
now look at this look at these stories
man here's my favorite one is the
reuters one where it says biden condemns
violence says trump recklessly
encouraging it
how dare trump you know how dare trump's
staff
donate to the the oh i'm sorry oh wait
it was biden stuff
oh i'm sorry from reuters biden staff
donate to group that pays bail in riot
torn minneapolis i remember this
well that was biden's staff oh yeah yeah
doesn't mean well okay well anyway it's
not like his vice presidential candidate
was actively encouraging people to
donate to the riot that'd be silly
oh here's a tweet from here's a tweet
from kamal harris if you're able to chip
in now to the minnesota freedom fund to
help post bail for those
protesting on the ground in minnesota so
wait wait i have an objection with this
okay kamala harris is supposed to be the
law and order
candidate right yeah so how does this
jive with this stupid tweet about
donating to the minnesota freedom
you know let me you know remember what i
mentioned last week like the bugs bunny
meme where he's like just leaning up
against the wall his eyes half closed
and he's like raised
that's how i feel right now just like oh
yeah you know oh yeah one of these again
huh yeah
listen i was talking to uh
wait a minute donate tim why is it why
does it go to kamala harris for the
people oh
it goes through her oh i see how this
works
what look at this act blue yeah it is no
kidding and it says uh kdh
social minnesota freedom fund ref code
but it says kamala harris for the people
does this who does okay it does go to
the minnesota freedom fund okay okay
i'm like that's kind of weird i was
talking to a family member who said that
in the suburbs of chicago people are
crossing their fingers that kamala
harris will be a law order candidate
who is going to shut down the extremism
and i just laughed when i heard it
i'm like dude the lady is so desperately
pandering to like
the far left you know why i just laughed
at this
do you know what the pro i'm doing air
quotes your protests were in minnesota i
mean of course you do
it was people running around burning
things down and they're still doing it
yep you know so so who is getting bailed
out
protests ah man you know what i i wonder
i think some of these democrats
genuinely believed they were peaceful
protests
maybe at first i'm not saying i'm not
saying the high profile ones
i'm saying there's a bunch of like you
know you know uh
dopey oh yeah you know not watching the
news
being like peaceful protests yes emily
harris on the other hand
i bet she's sitting in like a situation
room and she's like got a like a you
know a skyled face and she's like what
are they doing these buildings
ah we want their votes whatever tell me
what to tweet
yes and she just goes for it i imagine
that's exactly what she does in fact i
imagine tell me what to do is a lot of
what kamala
says because i don't think she thinks a
lot for herself
i think that she's i think that she's
constantly waiting for i got a gene no
you're
you're right but i think it's unfair
because
joe biden is like joe biden
isn't even able to carry out the
commands he's given you know what i mean
i didn't say this was unique to her
i just said that she especially is
really i i i get it i get it yeah but
but but uh you know joe biden yeah
that's fair
man what a dream team did you see the
clip from the joe biden presser he did
earlier yeah
where he was like can you believe that
in more than one year
uh with a hundred year and i'm like
what is it i don't know what you're
talking about dude
dude anyway so to see this like epic
gaslighting man
you gotta love it cernovich responded to
her on june 1st saying you are funding
domestic terrorism
uh-huh he got a thousand 100 retweets
and someone replied a day ago
this aged well indeed it did she did now
we got a uh a guy who was killed
walking down the street for those that
haven't been following the story with um
uh his name was aaron at danielson trump
supporter walking down the street in
portland
and it was targeted this uh this killing
so i'm sure most of you know by now this
story has been ridiculously massive
and it's it's one of the things they
asked trump about in this press
conference
the the the woman from cnn said you know
you want to condemn farther up to
violence put out your own supporters
the there were trump supporters had
paintball guns and stuff like that
trump spray pepper spray stuff yeah bear
with me yeah
and trump said you know you're pa
paintball like
look if they're going to defend
themselves from violence it's very
different from the bullets that were
used to kill
one of you know his supporters yeah and
it's true man well
first just just keeping it on biden
before we jump over to the uh
update on aaron danielson we got we got
to talk about the uh
you know the information that came out
from from a witness
trump allies challenge biden's tougher
tone on riots
note support for fund bailing out
protesters
donald trump is the most lawless
president in american history said biden
spokesperson
the last thing i just want to mention on
this because when i saw that gaslighting
it really did shock me
to my core i was just like the idea that
joe biden can for months be like look
fat
no support the protests peaceful
you know and kamal harris could be like
why don't everybody pitch in
and help you know bail out these
protesters
like for her to tweet them like that and
then do a complete 180
where now he's it was specifically that
he's saying trump is promoting this
when it was literally well to be fair i
want to make sure i'm very
careful in how i say this joe biden did
condemn the extreme violence
several times he did and i respect that
right however his staff has been
supporting it
and the underlying protest they've
absolutely supported and almost
exclusively
these protests have devolved into some
kind of chaos yep
real peaceful protests have been rare
here i've praised them every time
they've happened
and typically they don't get a lot of
news coverage and people complain about
it they're like doom
why won't you talk about the fact that a
thousand people marched with signs i'm
like i did i said it was great
yeah and i said if they wanted to sit
down and block the road i would never
probably civil disobedience it's great
but that's not what happened
like what do you want to do you want me
to like talk for a half an hour a bunch
of people walk down the street waving
signs it was great
anyway problem with peaceful protest
it's boring there's nothing really to
report no one gets hurt no one gets shot
people just demonstrate and they are
civilly disobedient sometimes but
what even that it can generate positive
press right
because it creates a story the problem
is they've escalated everything to a
certain degree
where yeah there's not a lot of news in
people walking around waving signs
unless it's massive so when this first
started i was thinking that enough
if enough conservatives would get out
and peacefully demonstrate that they
could make a big difference
but i am not convinced anymore because
what
what's the point to peacefully
protesting i mean i think an argument
here
i think i think i saw something from
cernovich a moment ago where he was
saying stay home
make money go vote yeah and i think it's
it's it's smart because the biggest
the thing right right now that's gonna
really really mess up trump supporters
is retaliation
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you